hello folks happy what days happy
Tuesday everyone we're gonna do two
streams today actually today's this this
is the first one it's gonna be Call of
Duty's new Call of Duty World War two's
new DLC resistance resistance which has
a new division has a bunch of new maps
it has a new zombie map as well I don't
know if we'll get to that has a new war
mode map which is pretty cool and has
new weapons I think as well yeah we're
gonna I got some blue crates that we're
gonna open and hopefully the supply
drops we'll have maybe the or so or one
of those other weapons so either you
have to buy loot crate's right or use
armor points so i can actually show you
guys right now for those that are
wondering how you get new weapons like
the or so so you can either catch them
in crates which would be like I think
rare versions of those weapons or if I
come here the supplies you need and I go
down to collections if I complete
specific collections I know I can unlock
them shoutout to our boy Richie on the
social team he was showing us how we get
it let's see if I can find it one of
them well I can't think of which one it
is specifically but one of them once you
unlock all the all the items underneath
that list you get one of the specific
orso's so well uh I guess we can start
this dream by opening some some crates
some some loot boxes we'll see maybe
we'll get lucky all right okay so we got
about 20 alum guys just doing let's run
through them and hope we got something
here we go
fingers crossed we're open for some
resistance items
nope emo junk is there is the back of
the card
representative oh oh there we go my
shingles all right
so Polish underground that's an epic
resistance outfit that's preset is not
new oh I need notice that it's shingles
for the stg44 that's pretty sick I have
the Red Baron I think I might gun right
now
junk pistol grips an emo so the
resistance has that little triangle at
the or that knife right there yeah mom
nope
junk city city city to be expected if
you want to do me a favor if you could
go online and pull up all the list of
items of everything that's like that's
come out sure that's included distance
and I'll keep chugging along alright how
many we done we've done four three camo
equipted I don't know I like my emblem
its GameSpot I made it myself
thanks Richie the backs of the cards do
you give it away they do okay
alright get a little mmm nope come on
baby don't worry you got the freezer a
that's cool
look at that awesome war hog alright
let's keep going
oh okay alright actually a pretty dope
helmet I know it's common but it is
resistance theme and so I can take off
that silly winter thing I don't know
what yeah exactly animal one our boy
here in the office dang that's a dupe Oh
Road Mountain that's chill I'm not sure
why I'm still pulling that's interesting
winter supplies you had 10 more all
right I think I'm gonna quickly we got
another epic doctor that's second you
all right is that a hat that's cool I'm
gonna quickly open up this tight because
I
believe these specific drops reduce the
risk of the other cold stuff yeah what
am i doing there we go let's call it
trying to find a list oh there you go
you're so sick so I think we now have
the or so yes but you see this will be
another resistance only alright cool
well that one was more successful
we got the or so I think I have a couple
more just regular resistances pop them
like as hot then we can get into
actually killing people you know anyway
how's everybody doing the chat how's
everybody's week's going did anyone stay
up late last night or early or whatever
time it is in your time zone and and
play some resistance when I first
dropped let's go some monsters oh wait
wrong video
all good arson I've been playing a lot
of monster I not gonna lie I haven't and
I'm having FOMO yeah I know it's not
really my kind of game but I'm having a
fun load the whole time people were
playing for that first week Oh a oh you
have it svt40 that's pretty sick so how
much more were those resistance only
boxes then oh that's lit that's cool I
like the shovel
Nick how much more were those all
resistance boxes only those I think were
included in the a bundle
see it to buy like 10 alright alright
weekly check and see what we got here
that or so on so we can check out that
new gun so it's under this machine gun
category there's your so oh there's a
Golden Goose alright and we're putting
the new resistance division what are the
works
oh that division I can use 35 not far
off of mine
I want that shovel oh can you check out
that division later for me the
resistance yes
let me quickly switch to the resistance
helmet sick like we have a full
resistance outfit now sure nice okay
cool there we are
so what do want me to check I wanted to
see the division well search for a match
and then look at the division I guess we
can take a look here triangle that's it
oh yeah
pistol tactical knife damn okay
scrambles additional pistol attachment
mini-map indicator yeah alright so yeah
pistol oriented class I guess
should we rock all the machine because
machine yeah yeah right token I have no
attachments for either yeah I all will
be leveling let's go alright cool
I'm just gonna run requisition so that
we get some kill streaks uh should we
hop right into I want the new orbs the
new war mode it's up to you you do
whatever you want
let's try hopefully people you know it's
like it's a random or do they have a
thing where it's like and you can vote
resistance I'm gonna vote for classified
beats the other one was Neptune which
we've already seen before says Neptune
though it does so I guess not tuned it
is shoot these usually pretty go pretty
quick as nothing's a tough one so
there's no way to actually just queue
for resistance to have that in old cards
I felt yeah I had asked
I'd asked Ritchie if it was possible and
he said no so I'll just have to vote
every time for it's something new you
guys see my cool emblem
it's the GameSpot G what's up creepers -
there's your shoutout I feel like this
is the best cod for me in a couple years
but I don't know if that's saying very
much
I just like to return to the boots on
the ground yeah me too but war mode was
fun but what mode is pretty much just
like battlefield stuff yeah let's see
how it is okay this is definitely the
wrong weapon to be using that
having feathering that man I'm trying to
figure out where actual um so just so
you guys know we're live everyday at 11
a.m. thank you guys all for tuning in
I'll be monitoring chat I switch off
with Nick here and there yeah but yeah
tune in later we're gonna we got a good
one later a hunt showdown we have closed
alpha is the new Crytek game it's like a
mix of PvP with PvE elements as well so
that's gonna be a 2 o'clock which is in
about 3 hours that alpha that close
alpha is like only a day which is I
think it's only 24 hours yeah which is
strange
so and then tomorrow at first it was
gonna be hunt until I found out was
anything for our o YP might mess around
a fortnight battle royale cuz that's C
oh oh you just got a knife I didn't I
got a knife by the new class there it is
Wow she got in there news murder tak
knife if it's like your big knife an old
Cod tak knife was kind of ridiculous but
that's because I'm your pistol you could
have it would lunge to a little bit if
you were far and then you could just
like slash the next guy that didn't look
as bad but that looked pretty fast
though yeah there is a resistance
playlist there is I don't know it all
right we yeah Devon said play the resist
I had spoke with our reto that was Ben
our resident Cod expert Ritchie and last
night yeah he's been playing he's been
playing a fair amount I believe what at
Apex ed resistance playlist okay we'll
do that next
it's fine I really honestly I haven't
touched this game since it's still a
card I know look at that guy
you want me to almost want you just to
leave oh just to leave so we can get
into the playoffs we can if you want
it's up to you how long this could take
a while we can leave we can do it I mean
yeah well forfeit the XP it's not a big
deal
alert alert ban that guy alright let's
get to that hot playlist do we find the
list of all right so featured yeah no I
can't I get in you don't have it
apparently right do you have a party
member in your group you or your party
member do not have the required content
Oh the season pass oh my gosh I need you
to do any favorite eh I need you to go
get Miguel and go grab a code because I
sent us are you sure they sent it yep
I'm positive
but they was told it was free for all
which it is in the meantime I'll play
some team deathmatch and hang out with
you guys
rookie mistake actually no this isn't
and here's why ah classified we were
told that the resistance oh bridge she's
going Thank You Richie they're Nazis of
passcodes it'll just be a resistance
code and we'll get the season pass
one-liner no I don't want to play on
London docks
hi Bob Jones it's going slowly but
surely yeah so right now everyone can
try it but I guess you can't get to the
resistance only thing unless we actually
physically download that specific code
which I thought you had well I didn't
know we needed I thought that everything
was going to be open to everyone I
didn't know those specific playlists
we're going to be locked up which i
think is kind of lousy all right
anyway we shall play resistance okay I
got one for you you got one all right
let's go off camera quick hi everyone
how's it going you might even have to
quit out of it potentially I'm really
hoping that you don't actually have to
install something I don't think so I
think it's just gonna give us access
I'll see no no faith no faith because if
you read verbatim it says you don't have
resistance installed we'll see about
that
okay I believe I'm gonna use the top one
can you guys guess the code based off of
him clicking about probably not okay
your mic is low it can't be what someone
moved a line on it and there you go
I'm also just not talking that loud
jeiza has a busy day today
yes it's never-ending he has a lot of a
destiny a coverage oh I already did that
already should be up there I think
they're just reading YouTube chats nope
that's not true Calvin no reading both
reading both you should tell Mary about
restream it'll stream for both her
platforms and give her both chats yeah
little Fei Long says how long is it you
have little faith
get out of here rip in pepperonis I was
right
and Nick was wrong no shock here as I'm
the older wiser one ah lol I am NOT
happy about that I'm not either you just
can't see it because I'm not just
winging it alright I'll just try to get
it in HQ
um war mode I don't think you can even
get it to be honest I bet you you can't
I'm pretty sure you're locked out of it
so the deal is is that resistance they
were going to open all the resistance
maps there was just some Sami mode and
everything for a specific time frame and
then when that time frame is up it would
become you would have to own it in order
to have it
oof is right trust yeah that man
no does that is brutal that's actually
brutal I'm almost positive you're not
gonna find any war unless it's still up
but I have a feeling that it's it's
going on
so that's a stream ever no [ __ ]
all you're gonna see is us playing the
division the new division for now cuz
that's what we have we do have a new gun
though so there's that I'm here to hear
taste reactor and laser from trade I
think it's gonna be good for the
Clippers I think this is the winner
mount the guy rid of a big contract and
they depending on how bad Detroit is
they'll get a first and second round
that are Ritchie says he has it if you
want to go grab his ps4 oh he has it ok
sounds good to me
I'll be right back alright I'll just
keep playing here ah sorry sometimes you
win sometimes you lose and today I lost
anyway well play with the resistance
class and weapon for a little while
until we get Ritchie's ps4 in here and
then we'll do that I really need to go
on a stream suspension for a little
while ah I am sad goob I'm extremely
disappointed well we have a new map even
though I think this is winter jim q what
happened lol we didn't download the
specific resistance code because we
thought that resistance DLC was open for
a little while to certain players
[Music]
cheese rounds going about as well as the
stream Jesus the skies killed me three
times now
[Music]
today's gonna get us all settled here
I'm done and also this is not a new map
this is just the winter version I
believe if someone could confirm that
sick
we have unmatched he's not a fans gun so
far but it's new nope jeez
you want me to unplug here
yikes this round is going like shi t
damn yeah I know why is this dude
chillin in the corner come on homie yeah
I see just hold me over here see if I
can sneak up on them nope Oh what up
[Music]
these guys out of another here small
areas
jeez Louise I found me and that guy go
area yeah
[Music]
all right
okay booting up a version that should
have the game top right is not a bad
spot actually yeah all right oh shoot
all night we got resistance so to speak
don't um is it gonna be a pain to get it
over here yes we're playing off this
monitor I'm not doing anything more
right okay acceptance okay nicely done
Oh nicely done I went written two fires
it fixed now eh about to be it's about
to be yeah assuming I can connect online
fingers crossed
where's this guy I know when I'm getting
close
no he's definitely on the stairs he up
Starwood I don't know I don't think it's
lagging all right I got it up now we
search for an actual match what do you
want you mosh pit yeah if it works then
we just hop in I'm just gonna leave it
on you until I actually get into a game
okay and then we can switch yeah I can
switch the feed whenever I want
it's just that I'm just in queue right
now it's narrowing my lobby search
oh nice he's got the horse Oh - yeah the
thing is I don't this this gun doesn't
really have much range that's the only
thing I'm noticing I mean obviously an
SMG breath but at least with some of the
other ones I get some range well like I
said you don't have any perks you there
all right yeah that's no excuse but your
switch alright switching we gonna play
together if you want
oh this isn't that good
what me no hair audio from this right
now I don't think there is audio or in
that yeah can't remember I could have
sworn there was something like
background music but I can't remember I
don't thinks Wow SEC I now quote we're
good eye
here we go I think you're seeing yeah
this is a resistance map he's not
inverted in his frickin sensitivity is
so high though we're blowing on
Ritchie's ps4 I have an or so right now
yeah we could play together if you want
to I guess I actually can you though cuz
you you don't own it yet right you like
you don't have a download video oh no I
can't
Wow I miss really bad they're sweet it's
all good me too dude am i lagging or was
that guy just running into me you might
be why
I don't think so I think you're good I
think you're gonna have to learn a
sensitivity all right
well either way what do you do you back
okay oh you can see how far the download
is oh god don't do it
don't shoot me through the box so you
are this is the or so this is the
regular Warsaw mm-hmm so the one that I
had a one baby or so yeah
I don't have that epic one that you had
probably like a lot better than Jesus uh
the epic one doesn't I think it's just
it's just a skin that's the difference
and I want like a temper mad recoil like
you I think it gives like a 10% like
boost for XP uh shout out Thank You
Richie for letting us borrow your ps4
yeah
me no like this dude okay I have red
ping sick I was like am i lagging I am
lagging I don't really know why though
the only thing I can think of doing is
like switching the internet connection
but that could be a real messy thing to
do to you so I'm gonna pull up a list of
like the information all the maps are
included in resistance and everything
let me kind of go over that dude red bar
life
yep didn't even see him throw the
grenade on the balcony except my flag
walking all right so you know what it
could be it's cuz you're downloading
probably hit pause and stop it pause on
that now maybe that's not it it's not
going away no I mean I don't think it's
that I'm gonna have to swap I might just
have to swap the ethernet cuz this is
unplayable like I am literally
teleporting I don't know if you had read
ping or not I don't know if you looked I
didn't look I didn't look I didn't see
you like warping like I am though so
just go over all the new multiplayer
maps that come with the resistance DLC
are anthropoid occupation which is in
Paris so you can see the Eiffel Tower
Valkyrie which is like a Nazi base like
this one it is unplug
there's a new war mode map operation
intercept let's see the next war mode
experience that type leads you to an
urban rescue mission to save resistance
fighters being transported by train the
first objective on the Allied side is
freeing the fighters followed by the
destruction of key communication
equipment at the and ends with stopping
the Train
so it's another new war mode which I
know you are reading the comments relax
yeah grandboy reading and there's a new
zombies chapter the darkest shore dart
ashore follows the heroes into our next
chapter of their dangerous journey only
days after the heroic disaster of
Middleburg the crew received Intel that
suggests dr. Straub is on an island just
north of Germany blanket in fog the
islands surrounded by Nazi air and sea
power and crawling with the undead murid
roastin Olivia and Jefferson will need
to battle this to uncover the hidden
mysteries within the dark as sure right
well there's no breeze hopefully this
works now I got a check right off the
bat though
yes so new zombies chapter new war mode
through new maps new weapons and oh look
I'm green bar thank God now I have no
excuse though Nick hmm my only excuse
will be that I don't know the map but
that's fine I will troll the chat and
chat with you guys sorry for those oh
look I got a double kill off green ping
okay things things things are looking ok
there and then it ended but that's fine
that made me instantly feel better about
myself which is what you got to do don't
forget that our resident stream expert
Eric Tay right here the streams everyday
on GameSpot's youtube and twitch around
11:00 a.m. Pacific time so that's 2 p.m.
Eastern today we're gonna be streaming
twice right yep so Cod now and then
what's later the hunt go down ok I lied
I'm terrible how are you doing what's
the point she has a tack knife what was
your favorite no yeah but this class has
a tack knife so why are we not using the
technology to switch bridge AAA again
big shout-out to Richie Breck amante who
hooked it up yes he aptly downloaded the
DLC even though I downloaded everything
and thought that included it but no
we have three new multiplayer maps only
war mode there's a new zombies chapter
resistance DLC for cod world war 2 how
much you said Cod world at war that's
funny that's been a while since that
game came out beta in my team right
there but whatever whatever it takes
currently using this is the yes which
seems like it has less recoil them
before he has a grip though you didn't
have a grip oh wow what's legit riches
alright that this is one of this is one
of his favorite SMGs really better than
all the other ones that are out cuz it
doesn't feel better than the ones that I
recall
Oh Ritchie says sorry I do lead to
complete a pistol challenge ok fair um
let's see
spawn on me says I believe in you Eric
on the twitch chat oh what's up man how
you doing
let's see I shouldn't have challenged in
there Scoob says enough blaming in the
leg dude it was read barring I was
literally teleporting your crate oh god
you're crazy if you don't think that
matters so this is the Valkyrie map the
Valkyrie map I believe is like a German
Nazi base that the resistance is
infiltrating so everybody you guys
should know obviously the resistance
takes into effect like the whole story
if you guys played the cod World War 2
campaign you know that the resistance
played a little bit of a role in that
in that campaign it was actually one of
my more favorite missions beasts it's
one of the more stealthy ones I won't
say anymore in case you want to play and
I don't want to ruin it for anyone
this isn't that good what bro protect me
because I have an SMG and the guy has it
like a AR oh nice according to this or
someone like right there
Oh what was that gun for resistor custom
like that okay harness the power of our
act no I think whoa that's some of these
like emblems are crazy I don't even look
at that thing on the top right
oh wait I'm blocking it with our tip
whatever oh hey wonder if Ritchie has a
like build that's like or so but with no
I wanted it the or so with her tack
knife like the whole point of her pistol
class but whatever so those those of you
in the chat for anyone that's played
resistance so far God maybe tried out
some of the new weapons maybe the new
maps would err what are your guys's
favorites what's your favorite weapon
and why were the best attachments for
some of the new weapons I'd be
interested to know oh he knew he knew
yeah he did jump shot to me to you it
was good that's good back out here okay
yeah I knew no I was a guy killed he was
like not that guy is dying
[Music]
we opened some of the crates the supply
drops already so if you're on YouTube I
believe you can scrub back to the
beginning you can see some of the supply
crates of yoga some of the resistance
gear wheel my husband
not terrible but not good do better in
my first round a lot better by first
round and on my first round with the red
ping was a mishap easy red ping that
still counts there no footsteps oh come
on No
it's getting ready to go kill the other
guy and then didn't even kill her
YouTube mod anvil one Ryan Schubert here
I know he when this game came out was
playing a ton of cod World War two and
another shoutout for him again shoutout
to Ritchie for having this downloaded
and shout out to Ryan for helping if you
guys saw our prestige weapon guide that
we did on GameSpot I feel good about
that I guess
Ryan was amazing and grinding it out
getting all those sick new weapons
we are currently playing on the ps4 yes
just want to use like an STD in cold day
[Music]
used to be so much better going prone
faster I can't do it anymore
oh the dolphin dive yeah you gotta like
claw it and I don't claw yeah guy got me
behind them taking Baker Dacron 12 once
no is this going to mess up your destiny
gameplay after you adjust to Cod
controls it's not even that dude I
haven't played destiny is so long it's
um I've been playing Monster Hunter I
don't know how to play anything but
wasps around right now so
hey in adapting then djenka our our John
Luke I'm catching up I'm behind you
three are like Monster Hunter experts
right Jamie yeah no thank you
thank you Ron Schubert for all the help
with that I'm out here I'm prestige
weapons that was a lot of work and you
pretty much did most of it just got a
camp there spawn baby no don't take a
[Music]
bounce it off the tree
why the drop on them that's [ __ ]
terrible part of my French pardon your
francais grande boy teen YouTube says
what's the difference between GameSpot
and Game Stop Game Stop is the retail
video game store GameSpot is our online
publication where you can find all kinds
of video gaming news reviews and
everything you want especially like live
streams that happen everyday at 11 a.m.
Pacific 2 p.m. Eastern with our
screaming my score Eric attack bleep
bleep oh god no no good job other guy
he's doing what I was doing to them
she's camping their spawn dirtied is in
the twitch chat wants to know what we
think about Snoop Dogg stream I think it
was pretty hilarious what's it called
again this show I don't know what this
show is called keygasm run with name of
the show is I watched the first episode
I thought I was kind of interesting what
he's able to get away with but yeah
that's pretty cool
hi fish man 15 what's up dude welcome to
the live stream thank you for joining us
thank you all for joining us
our Sean you've been killing it in the
chat answering people's questions
yeah whoo whoo went a little wound up
got a little one there got a little one
they're just reporting brother no wasn't
was its on your feet that's why so we
can do I just wanna make sure that that
wasn't oh look it's me hit man Brock
we got that kill feed nice camping in a
little corner Richie yeah we don't do it
on the weekends unfortunately Bam Bam
Richie says this map looks fun
Richie have you not played it yet all
right I saved I salvage my score I
salvaged it it was looking a real dire
you just gotta get the hang of it
that's all I actually just have to sng
how do I don't Alan Eric to do some 360
done dude first of all Calvin we don't
take donations second of all I can't
even kill things in front of me so spawn
homey camping is the best way yeah
actually it kind of is how do I donate
one Eric to do some 360 trick shots dude
he's got some crazy one what is this
what is that how do I undo a wield it oh
so good no no hustle
where's the running gun one yeah there
you go
sorry oh gee he's got 23 you got 23
you'll be fine
Steve 9 9 4 and twitch wants to know
what you thought of the new map I
thought that was fine I mean all the cod
maps are kind of the same right I don't
fire from the hip really I also agree
with dirty third is they do need zombie
skins for multiplayer I think that would
be really cool frog this is prog right
you tell me I'm terrible yeah I think
that was the Prague Castle are poor yeah
right here
this is cool Wow [ __ ] I'm gonna try that
the knifing thing because that's what
it's supposed to do you're gonna have it
just down Lee you should probably just
put in a rest
go faster protip we check on it later
assuming it finishes our paint jobs in
the game says dab oh yeah there are you
can get skins for your weapons
I thought doesn't feel that fast look at
the skin on that that's cool skin this
is not feel that fast but alright we'll
try try to make the dream happen I don't
feel like I'm running that fast either
it was totally like some one right here
I'm gonna have to work so it nice nice
[ __ ] knife dumb who's mid reload Stephen
twitch says I found the campaign this
code to be okay
what are everybody else's thoughts on
the cob campaign for World War two is it
a firm yes or I don't really mind or
firm new behind but knifes gotta be
situational right don't mind me not
doing the hard point at all for me
personally I really enjoyed the I really
enjoyed the campaign from this game ah I
got I got learned the map here first
time in praha you in Prague broke
beautiful city
it's interesting if you actually go to
Prague today and you go on one of the
tours I mean granted this was back when
I did the tour it was back in 2011-2012
you can actually see the damages before
I could est g'd mean see I love the STG
oh shoot France bond camp
yes cyborg Manson Czech Republic but if
you go there and visit and you do these
tours just kind of like one on the city
you can see the effects of the war in
the architecture there's a lot of like
bullet holes still in some of the old
buildings from World War two there's
obviously a lot of statues and whatnot
how did that not kill him I don't know
the grand not that matter
that's my new heart point we're losing
oh we're in rekt oh we got the hard
point though no we don't I've always
been uh at least in the world in this
game I always chose a arse over smg's
yeah cuz I like the range Oh God just
kidding
Adam it's 95 wants to know is the DLC
worth the asking price in our opinion
I haven't played enough I don't think
tey is played enough but with that being
said it is a season pass
I know it's I think it's $49.99 plus tax
I believe sledgehammer and Activision
have some pretty significant plans for
DLC that will be included in the season
pass this is just part one I don't know
how many ports I can check for you guys
now but it depends on how much you play
the game of course yeah it's having a
little friendly duel with the guy and
then I get bombed a leak on on YouTube
are we playing on PC no we are playing
on ps4
my lord please Eric
play better you're playing great no I
believe in you I'm better than this Nick
I believe in you you got killed her from
behind yep that's welcome to call of
duty all right so if you were to
purchase the cod World War 2 season pass
it is experienced a full-scale theater
of war with the season pass continue the
epic journey with four DLC packs and
2018 that include iconic multiplayer
maps new chapters as nazi zombies and
all new war mission modes so right now
this should be one yeah this is one so
there are three four or three more
updates that are coming every time those
updates will all probably be around the
same size I'm assuming so about three
multiplayer maps a new war mode and a
new chapter for nazi zombies nice
getting the hardpoint yeah there across
the way though with like ranged weapons
yeah
and grenades no I think artillery strike
yeah they're playing is smart
we are not yeah we can even get on high
I have not there's no no specs on this
because it's its ps4 I have not played
the cod on PC to be honest wow that
guy's good I don't um I don't know what
it's like I Michael hi um our tech
expert along with Jimmy thank they
checked out cod World War 2 on PC and
said that it still played like a console
game so
let's see oh there's too many they're
posted up your team doesn't seem to be
supporting you
oh I like that tag dank it's not so much
about that it's just we're not getting
enough kills to like really control that
the hardpoint
and they have kill streaks that they're
clearing out any hard points that they
can't get to I'm wondering if prop hunt
is included in the deal in the
resistance mosh pit if it is that can be
super fun what prop hunt is that is back
it's a new multiplayer mode pretty cool
that's where you search for specific
items on the map I'm not sure I know
Ritchie was playing Evan - that would be
some old stuff ah bushing Ryu Katz's at
GameSpot and chat hi I just walked in
please tell me the resistance DLC will
make me feel like the resistance from
insomniac games what's up Oh prop hunt
is over already that's sad Ritchie says
that's actually sad why wouldn't I just
leave it spray-and-pray
getting this is oh it says equipped
another gun I'm not sure if we have any
of the other resistance guns unlocked
yet Ritchie if you're still there in the
chat well thank you guys unless there's
something I don't know that I guess yeah
I'm actually sad too along with Ryan I
need to play prop hunt either I didn't
rise it was a timed exclusive so weird
prop wasn't gun game or problem with two
faves please we have like three guys
there can we please hold one point
maybe if I killed somebody can't hold
the point if we can't kill people
Wow first was 1620 that's not good that
is not good I saw a flash of zombies
when they showed the trailer zombies in
the 1940s maybe just kill us early next
map please you're just toying you at
this point
and pretty much they're like don't even
get the hard point just toy with them
from downtown well if it means anything
this map is beautiful
Thanks name I think you're playing great
I think your team is is dropping the
ball for you yeah I could be better
I've oh man I want to take his STD so
bad oh look I got to the hardpoint I'll
play one more and then we'll switch
dirtied is can you throw frags back I
don't think oh he's using nowhere so I
think no you you should keep going
you're getting used to it at this point
so keep going all right where are we
from
we are you can throw [ __ ] back weekend
we're based in San Francisco wow we had
a guy that was 2 and 22 how is that even
possible
that's pretty good that would be me if I
was playing so no you know why don't you
take it down to enemy's weapons because
I'm trying to show off the new gun yeah
not doing a great job of it though but
Raj says you can be better that's really
yeah I think I definitely could be
better I thought you did great no no we
got it we got to get out we got to get a
nice low around here Oh Danny says the
new gun sucks no or so yeah I'm not a
fan of it right now but I don't know how
I feel about it either but
I can I can understand
yeah no no not a huge fan here late
there's one is I think the one at the
bottom is new
that's a rifle yeah yeah I saw someone
had that I was gonna pick it out I
should try to pick that up as the you
guys know if the guerre is new I think
the guerre is new to this one yeah or
that might be from the winter I think
that might be from the winter are you a
zombie player now are you gonna play a
zombie
probably not but yeah you play good you
guys strategize ah yeah just don't agree
I mean I don't I'm not like the pro Cod
players wouldn't it wouldn't know where
to the next hard point is I guess
alright this is another map oh no oh
yeah this is occupation this is the one
that takes place near the Eiffel Tower
this another gallery great
sorry Ritchie looks like it's gonna be
that kind of day I don't know yeah where
was from the winter event right okay
thank you
Oh
are you in heart pointer is this just
what you're catching the mosh pit mosh
pit is just what it's just what the mosh
pits giving me I had domination that
other one there you go your teams I was
like why are we so close together and
that guy just gets the dream grenade on
us oh here we're gonna we're gonna
bundle up again
yeah the guerre was in world world at
war I believe goodness for that headshot
fatally Kobe what was what was
everyone's first call of duty in the
chat this obviously depends on how old
you are but warfare to you baby
really that was your first one I don't
know Amano warfare sorry and then
without like my friend had it so I had
to play on his he'd have to bring it
over I I had mono warfare to you though
yeah so I think the first one that I
played myself was called duty to the
volkswagen the volkswagen was too and
then the first one i really played
online a lot was yeah i will agree with
goop on this one my first actual shooter
like this was Medal of Honor it was the
Pacific the Pacific one that opens with
Pearl Harbor I don't remember that
specific one
Wow wines was modern warfare 3 how's
this first one Cod one was awesome
that's his penny that was yeah I agree
epidemics is the only one I played the
most online is modern warfare 3 I think
I played modern warfare 2 the most with
my friends online
oh no we're on a nice little streak
there I got quickscoped probably quick
scoped again same guy link yeah I just
zoomed it's good
yeah Medal of Honor was was a rad series
back in the gym not I mean I know what
happened but surprised shooting the
cement oh if you guys have any questions
for teh questions for future streams and
stream schedules please post them up in
the in the chat for your quick no joke
Bob Jones is dropping some frames
dropping some frame down might be on
your end bomb if anyone else is the same
yeah can anyone else confirm or deny
it's artillery oh it is okay yeah don't
worry about it
oh um oh yeah you're right
but I don't you have to have oh damn
that guy is really good yeah yes no he's
somehow not doing that hot but it could
be just his team I caught that voice
crack was in me it's probably me my
voice cracked so often I just kind of
ignore that uh bob says just for a
second that's good enough okay ooh Coby
wants to know what you guys do another
Dragon Ball Z fighters stream on ps4
maybe especially well when the DLC
characters come out of course they're
gonna stream it be sure to check out
gamespot.com
there's currently an awesome article
about the characters we want to see the
DLC characters we're we're looking
forward to coming to fighters what are
you what are you guys playing right now
are you guys playing called duty Monster
Hunter Dragon Ball fighters I said
Dragon Ball Z fighters and in there so
horrible all right pick it up these
aren't Matt these maps are kind of small
I'm realizing they're always small man
it's Cod epidemic how much do these DLCs
on their own I'm into it I'm into it
right now but I don't think oh the
spirit
I wanted a knife I'm so glad but he was
in a turn I can look I don't can you you
I mean I'm sure you can purchase these
DLC is one at a time but
and also just so everyone knows the
resistance DLC pack one is early that's
why we're playing on ps4 because it's
it's it's early like it really access
for only that what's called a grip a
gang load damn weird oh I agree with
Sagittarius hope to release date for
Spidey on ps4 is out soon you and me
both guys are pretty good at the sniping
I'm only super thankful we got a release
date for what's it called got a war oh
my lord where did you come from
all right so if you were to purchase DLC
one it is $15 so $14.99 Thank You Roger
Wow just getting rekt by the sniper guy
alpha to six says the occupation map is
the best one in my opinion great flow
great nostalgia from modern warfare 3 it
is out early for season pass holders
says Richie oh my god just doing an a
back to myself awesome
such Terry says I'm still playing
monster hunter world you're allowed to
still be playing since it just came out
there goes that and our huge lead is
gone it's time for a guy probably picked
it up yeah shouldn't be checking my
score please now you can check your
score no don't miss 10 oh the Sten
that's gun
grandboy teen you're playing the game
watching at the same time yes we are
keeping an eye on and we're keeping an
eye on the twitch and YouTube chats
that's why there's too easy taking focus
on the game and I can focus on answering
questions now the guys chatting you know
the deal like you hardpoints SMG life
and not about it you can switch I mean
we're on the new map no point no or so
only deal we'll deal with you were on
the top of the board for your team them
doesn't mean anything in my humble
opinion this is epidemic twitch says ah
so this is the modern warfare 3 map I
thought I was tripping is it Tootsie
I think it's just a night like a 1940's
version of when I would be it was 43
what even happened there
Viraj no I'd died to something else
pelipper says you guys seem a bit down
today I was a little bummed out earlier
because I was under the impression that
no the resistance mode yeah no I missed
the second knife I was under the
impression resistance mode was gonna be
open to everyone for a certain time so I
simply downloaded the update without
locking in the codes we received this
morning that is not the case you have to
have specific things pre-ordered in
order to get that speed a little bit of
a bumpy beginning Bor here we're here
we're happy we're playing some cod we're
gonna play some I already forgot the
name of the game again later oh the hunt
the hunt showdown we're gonna explore
hunt showdown showdown there goes that
yeah so another stream later you guys
know about what time to - okay so 5:00
p.m. Eastern 2 p.m. Pacific you can see
the hunt showdown hello
Jacopo I hope I said that question is
neck trunks as good why would I be drunk
no I'm not drunk it's noon on a Tuesday
although the club often goes up on a
Tuesday we've been playing for about an
hour
well maybe we'll run till about 12:30
Pacific
I got axed something dude that seemed
his melee seemed faster than that melee
there's two guys are in front of me do
you say aka Pooh's day am i right like
how I kept Adem ik
I am NOT a day drinker but on the
weekends well no I'm not a weekday day
drinker on the weekends I am dilly dilly
gonna be a great Sunday
wow that was Kofi got fadeaway didn't we
got Super Bowl mmm I want filly to win
just cuz I don't like the Patriots foot
I think Patriots win as a Giants fan God
don't work let's go to war mode lets you
uh let's do war mode yep yep damn dude
and that mean probably yep
quicks go get the Ford get the quad
welcome to call of duty Tim Sauter days
are for the boys that's correct that is
correct except for Sunday's though this
Sunday's gonna be a great day I actually
can't wait I think it's gonna be a good
game I think I'm scared man like if I
think your boy Nick Foles don't think
Foles is equipped like keenum in the
same vein that like how do I get at war
operation intercept 24/7
oh that's fast holy killcam I know
Richie those unreal yeah welcome to
quick scoping I guess I could never do
how old do you think that person was 20
is probably a teens 20s
no it's can be teens all right they'd be
in school so twenties yeah as a ryan
says in the YouTube chat I am a
conflicted fan it's a Giants fan I have
no idea who to root for I heard that
there's an asteroid that's supposed to
be passing very close to Earth that day
on Super Bowl Sunday so maybe if the
asteroid would just you know I think I
can get away with the or so Stadium
taking out both teams what am I supposed
to do on this one
I should tell you rescue the freedom
fighters I think you're at the end box
physics damn it I'm gonna do some
stabbing I don't care how bad it gets he
gonna stab he gonna stab you just don't
stab the people you're trying to rescue
hello Gonzales what's going on consult 1
2 3 welcome hello hey optic Vince
cyborg man says I hear doctor who's and
zombies is it true I have no idea
yeah the asteroid answer is what I've
been going oh
the knife is not as forgiving as it used
to be I guess used to just be able to
like there they're nice he's dead oh
yeah we got a rescue our boys would be
you think you know what would have been
a great Super Bowl though Nick Foles vs.
Blake bortles god no what are you even
know I gotta actually open the door yeah
you have to plan an explosive and they
can they can unplanted I think I don't
think he's gonna happen dude does anyone
know where this map is in retrospect to
like the game is it somewhere deep in
France or is it near like a major city
is it this is also tough for you to try
to dive into a war mode that was already
man match they've already had a second
to like figure out where things are and
what the objectives are it's got a
rescuer boys oh then tied these ones we
gotta get to the other side now yeah we
got a chance here you have some time
three of three at the other
um yeah I'm all about portals dude Jag's
are gonna try to get Kurt cousins or
yeah they are they are Kurt cousins I'll
be cool what was the question
do they have custom skins like pass
games they have like heroic and like
legendary weapon skins that like give
you a slight boost on XP they have some
pretty cool different bear it's their
like weapon variants there's some cool
ins sweet hair ok alright switching
sides defending is always easier oh I
think it depends on which one defending
this like almost always easier yeah beat
them up wow those mess up yeah you're
coming to save your peeps
I mean ye hmm why are you what are you
using oh I don't know actually it's a
second or whatever his second class was
that's all coming do you think they over
make tanks playable multiplayer like in
world at war says cyborg man no I don't
think so I'm disappointed but I don't
think so I think that's a I think that's
now a feature of bf one that separates
it Wow really there he set them free
geez
turns out defending is a lot harder than
I thought
no lease I got him off of it person
where the hell is there as a team we
only have one spot to defend no [ __ ]
I Ford cool its RAM can i play i I think
that update when I was downloading is
about 4.5 gigs for the resistance so
[Music]
vicious rapper says I like chase Keenan
but the Vikings need a solid QB you mean
Case Keenum
never heard of no chase keenum I don't
know why people are talking about GTA in
chat but hashtag I can't wait for Red
Dead Redemption
nice marksman or so well use on fire bro
I'm melting
[Music]
oh that's lit Oh God Wow Mac okay take
it I guess I don't know what that guy
was doing destroy the radio oh wait so
there's certain radios that you want to
protect and certain ones you want to
destroy no they destroy your radios what
oh so if it's red it's been destroyed so
you want to protect the green ones yeah
so it's like operation Neptune in the
middle section with the radios Oh ghost
shadow that's a tough that's a tough
question
do you think the Giants Garrity Eli I
don't know no range I guess I got short
arms oh my god I went yellow just to get
one kill them they didn't even give me
that to answer your question in short I
don't want the giant Sierra to Eli I'd
rather them kind of like fade him out
slowly or now Yoko Rosen you'll go Rosen
and then have your I want Rosa day well
I don't know if but I definitely know
one on Sam Donald Donald looked terrible
in the cotton ball absolutely atrocious
Lee terrible
there's gonna be a tidge from spawn one
the rio grande boy teen i took the
conversation GTS yeah read that two's
gonna be sick yeah a rumored summer
release I don't know though we shall see
on the time the toe fall back to the
train station yeah I was trying to do
what he did I didn't know about that's
fine that's nice
halt him
I agree with uh with grandboy teen the
graphics do look pretty fantastic I
think one of the things that was the
most impressive was the cutscenes in
this particular games and this games
campaign
I thought the cutscenes are really
really detailed and pretty pretty
beautiful characters looked amazing it's
so awkward to watch the tank just like
go backwards Oh God
I thought I was spawning closer than
that again just reminder GameSpot goes
live every day oh really you can't open
it from that's oh yeah I can I can 11:00
a.m. Pacific 2:00 p.m. Eastern Tay is
typically on every stream except for the
Monster Hunter one that they kind of
started all my legs come hang out
interact and chat watch some games chat
about games but in order to do that make
sure you hit the subscribe button on
YouTube and hit follow on Twitch so that
you get notified when tagos live every
day the GameSpot crew will join him
hanging out with you guys chat I know
I've gotten gotten to know a couple of
you personally and just kind of like
from streaming stuff like that's always
good yes definitely at the subscribe
button
you hit it I'll give you a little shout
will say what's up oh yeah I was a good
spot for actress 12:20 now maybe we'll
play one more war road war mode round
and then we'll call it because we've
seen all three metal god we've seen the
new class we've seen some knifing we've
seen some of the new weapons once we
have unlocked
right when it hits a Pater right there
yeah you know you died 17.25 times
yeah probably more than that actually
shoot you well we've seen both cut
seasons all right good job lions dang
that's pretty bad all right one more try
see how it goes
again a couple shout outs numero uno
shout out Ritchie bracamontes a on our
social team the meme King thank you for
letting us use your ps4 and your account
you know you'd a real MVP thank you to
our buddy Ron Schubert and Ville won in
the YouTube chat for keeping the chat
civil and for also helping out with some
of our other Cod content you are also
the real MVP and thank you guys all for
joining us and hanging out with shingles
I love that gun I don't know hmm just
looks long the Red Baron is my favorite
even though it doesn't make any
difference the yellow on you put a
little red dot on there woah it's lit I
don't use red not on this gun I really
wish I was what you would call it though
hey hey Thank You Richie using the
YouTube chat hanging out oh just
composing some dank memes for a Facebook
page you guys don't follow our Facebook
you should we got a couple of watch
channels - one of them's called today I
learned the other is called who
remembers make sure to check those out
those are pretty dank if you like dank
maymays you should check it out alright
time to try to play real good I guess
um yeah
thank you everybody in the chat for me
and uh homies you guys are all awesome
oh yeah that's right you stay there shot
that lady's got an eyepatch I know
cool seen some [ __ ] that's cool I'm
defending a I guess composing them dank
maymays well you're gonna hear this
who they smart
I just prized that mg Nest has the
ability to shoot up that hallway to your
right there's some homies are you bro I
try to creep up and snipe me our Sean
says whoa gamespot rocks thanks dude I
know it's 2:00 in the morning your time
thanks for hanging out with us so late
maybe getting off the nest was a bad
idea
oh wow this handles a lot slower who
that man all right he saw us he saw us
he might die that's fair
[ __ ] B Nobi is free doughnuts stop it
dank maymay TSA's dacron twelve on
Twitch should I call you dankaran twelve
so they have B right I defend a mm-hmm
can anyone tell me where the maymay joke
came from they are releasing some prison
odds oh yeah
screwed that up need to kill him before
he got into that room and had advantage
with this shoddy on me dude there's a
guy right behind you it confused me for
a second I was like wait
oh he's not on my team great zap release
the prisoners
nice
my nickname one here's the service tank
room co-pilot Nick you watching the map
no sorry
watching you guys hanging out with you
guys hello Pierluigi what's going on
nice stairs Steven in the YouTube chat I
respectfully disagree cod is one of the
more popular games although you might
not play it it is consistently Cod
destiny and Madden are consistently some
of the top performing games every year
although they come out every year
whoa okay I was like I didn't get
shotgun there's a guy over there they're
gonna blow this wall down could you
please look behind you bro Rainbow six
siege just getting some love in the chat
yeah they're player they're player base
is blowing it uh there's a new update
coming soon right yep zombie mode two
trout it's called
be on the lookout on game spots
dang you guys would love the new air
hurts better than the STG because of
that Richie oh okay
which one is it idea what to call Richie
you know too late try can't equip it I'm
not sure if he has unlock too
be on the lookout on gamespot.com
GameSpot's youtube channel for some
Rainbow six siege coverage
soonish don't wanna give any deets um
any specific details but there's some
stuff on its way from our buddy Michael
my Hardy damn buddies go clustered up
operation chimera thank you cyborg man
wait did I hear that right
zombies in siege I believe so yeah yeah
GameSpot will definitely be covering
just to reiterate wouldn't ryan
Schubert's then they'll be definitely
covering the upcoming siege stuff as
long as with some more in-depth looks at
some some of the stuff in siege I
believe there's some interesting
interviews and trips and things planned
very soon in the meantime though this is
cod World War 2 resistance DLC pack 1
pack 1 of 4 from the season pass he was
feeling that there weren't you I was
about to go flanking knife 2 or 3 or the
only thing but uh I was probably not the
right call because they were probably
gonna lose it now because I kind of like
to stop camping just the name of the
game essentially can repair
but it's gonna be close to obese they've
lost a significant amount of time on the
are the good spots here
on the time we snuck up on the tank yeah
that's how long on our team would have
been smart enough to shibam Sarat says
how are you guys doing today we're doing
well
it's Tuesday almost a hump day it's
always a good day when you come into
work and check out new games and new
DLCs and stuff like this
so always a good day if you guys are
enjoying this but and you enjoy butts
hit that like button hit the subscribe
button on YouTube hit the dip the follow
button on Twitch and then you'll be
notified when T goes live and he can say
butts butts oh this is not good ya see
that guy was juggling jumping over like
I was you're in the train station dog
choo choo
no arguing in the chat please
y'all are getting heated about video
game engines and developing plants of
cada your boys and girls I wanted oh no
oh no that bro huh yeah that's fine if I
could open a fricking door to save my
life he's just waiting for you oh crap
[Music]
reverse it reverse the payload he's on
top Oh at least kill him
you're prone there the whole time he's
doing with these with us to do though
just stopped
oh that shotgun dude is just the right
thing we're about to lose here
guys got a 4-time scope nice like trying
to like aim down the sights when he's
this close
craigory 99% it's over it is 12:30 3ds
when you play the other side see if it
actually puts us on the other side it
will it's only 10 minutes did better
that time
oh we're flavor the top yeah there you
threw kills you know no problem I know
is how many times I died though probably
just as many but which is the does he
have
is it the snake dynamo so just go into
one of the go into one of the things I
can't switch now I mean I can't
we try the dynamo I don't know what the
hell the dynamo is don't worry don't
worry we got you oh this is a shotgun
[ __ ] grabbers white boy Oh No how long
has this been out I think since midnight
30 days exclusively on the ps4 kill
Tolan try that again Call of Duty deals
world war ii dlc one pack resistance
it's all resistance fee French
Resistance someone's definitely behind
this wall will blossom dude dang it I
demolished it though let's go I got a
shotgun the Dynamo soon we get a decent
range actually please shotgun please is
it take more than one shot I guess so I
am NOT a huge hole not either fan I said
it in my little prestige weapon thing
it's on youtube if you guys wanna watch
it that I think the most overrated class
/ overrated prestige weapon that's not
even worth the grind is the sawed-off
shotgun now I know in the latest update
it got a buff still that sawed-off
shotgun man you hit him two times
doesn't even kill him and you're like
what you gotta reload that fish Cray dog
there's that guy there are you shotgun
the resistance and y'all I missed it I
tried to shotgun that's pretty smart
actually just camping the door with a
knife
what do you alright here's a question
for chat and for two if he if he knows
so obviously this year or 2017 with
sledgehammers year four how does it not
kill him shotgun let me shoot you in the
back of the shotgun see if that doesn't
kill you
so obviously this year 2017 call it Call
of Duty World War two with sledgehammer
games is addition their entry in the
series 2018 will be what is it the other
dev I don't know
Treyarch Infinity Ward you know and then
well essentially the question is what do
you guys think will the next game
continue this world war two trend or
will it be another black ops will it go
a completely different direction good
modern warfare like what do you what do
you guys think is gonna happen no [ __ ]
nice
oh you guys right
oh yeah what do you guys think the next
one that's gonna be cool guess who that
is a great comment Bob Joan says on
Twitch I just want the next Cod game to
be on switch I agree that'd be sick goob
I'm not gonna play today's day has
gotten the experience we're at the end
of the stream my ps4 was not prepared
for this
my bad no you guys just untie them
prison oohs oh good knife call do you
Vietnam this is black noise maybe so it
is it's a Treyarch year another black
ops so maybe we'll see sachet Arius I
don't know I don't know I think it would
be black ops to be honest I think it
would you block ops what is it for die
[Music]
it's true that radio command dog howl
shoot it shoot bang bang it was worth it
I killed a couple of radios no more
radio killer legends legends fate says I
would buy it on Steam but has a lot of
mixed reviews on there and I ain't
wasting $60 so I think the reason it has
mixed reviews is because there's
obviously the great debate over Cod as
is most games that come out year after
year after year so yeah it's it's
interesting I think that it's become a
trend in gaming where people feel the
want and or need to kind of bash call
duty not saying that this is like some
game changing like incredible video game
that you've gotta experience but I think
that like Cod every year makes
consistent but consistent improvements
they are obviously really in tune with
taking into effect the communities wants
slash needs so it's caught it caught it
every year there's really nothing you
can change about that if it wasn't
selling they wouldn't be doing it every
year and it does it sells so you had a
business and you're selling fresh foods
and people kept coming to eat them why
would why would you stop
but that's all that's all I'm a simple
eyes a good spot I can do anything with
it
we're all the radios at left
nice and then a win you gotta escort
though again you know cod is great but I
you know our Sean says cod is great but
I feel like you're stuck in the same
kind of gameplay mechanic yeah it is
like what are you gonna do read like
essentially like it ain't broke don't
fix it I think there's certain mechanics
they improve every year that but they're
never gonna change the overall way to
games damn and then a win let's go
yeah always optimizing new graphics
zombies modes I think one of the best
decisions they made in 2017 was taking
zombies mode and kind of encompassing a
horror element kind of like that horror
survival genre which I think Resident
Evil did really really well geez how did
that not kill no craft nobody's
escorting us
oh yes I would like to mow people down
it's fine thanks sniping
84% minute 55 no shop alone though we're
good we're good we're good we're good
just don't let him kill me from the
sidecar man
97 97 96 Oh close oh they're pushing you
back
alright so Charis we understand their
trash talkers in the chat but is it that
hard to just be respectful triple kill
yes yes yes yes finish strong oh my
goodness
sick - like dig real deep to win there
well ladies and gents let's watch a
little and cinematic that was all good
at the end yeah I guess so
call of duty world work to use DLC pack
1 the resistance we saw some new
resistance maps we saw the three new
maps we saw the new war mode sorry we to
get to zombies I maybe will do a feature
something like that yeah
don't forget in an hour yes in an hour
and 15 minutes here take it
today we'll be streaming the hunt show
showdown showdown hunt showdown the new
high-tech game it's like a PvP with PvE
yeah you'll see so I won't be the one
playing I think it'll be like Rob or
Aran yeah but yeah thank you guys for
hanging out with us thanks for dealing
with the hiccups at the beginning and as
always we'll see you next time yeah
thanks guys later yeah
ready will happen all my orders
by 50